here's the star of dirty dancing and
ghosts and a former sexiest man alive
how many are there ladies and gentlemen
mr. Patrick Swayze
during the days of silent films theaters
used music to great effect to underscore
the action and the emotion on the screen
and every theater in the country had a
resident orchestra in the pit an organ
backstage or at least a piano in the
wings to accompany the films but the end
of silent films didn't mean the end of
movie music tonight the Academy
recognizes this by presenting a sample
of the five nominated scores they will
serve as underscore for a series of
dance impressions this work was
choreographed by Debbie Allen who also
did such a wonderful job on last year's
Oscars and no wonder she was my mom's
student the music will be supplied by
our Orchestra under the direction of
Academy Award winner
maestro bill Conti
here are the nominees for original score
you
yeah way to go Debbie
once again the nominees for this award
are Alan Menken for Beauty and the Beast
Ennio Morricone for Bugsy George Fenton
for the Fisher King John Williams for
JFK
James Newton Howard for the Prince of
tides and the Oscar goes to Alan Menken
for Beauty and the Beast
on behalf of all the composers I want to
thank Debbie Allen for that that was
just great I'd like to thank the members
of the Academy in particular the members
of the music branch for this honor at
Disney I want to thank Jeffrey
Katzenberg Roy Disney Peter Schneider
our producer Don Hahn art directors Kirk
wise and Gary Trousdale and our
brilliant animators and I can't say
enough about my music team my
Orchestrator Danny true conductor David
Freedman recording engineers John
Richards Michael Farrow Bruce Botnick
many thanks in the Disney music
department Kris Montana Andy Hill my
music editor Cathy Bennet my love and
thanks to Janice Anna and Nora my mom
and dad my manager Scott chucat and most
of all I thank my late partner and
friend Howard Ashman Howard I wish you
could have seen the finished product I
wish you could have heard the completed
score I know you would have been proud
thank you